got beautiful skies out there we've got
some clouds that have been around
overnight and now they're starting to
slide off to the north so you can see
the blue sky off to the south so we'll
get some clearing and then we'll get
some clouds coming back
excuse me temperatures have been in the
very mild 50s overnight because of the
clouds not much wind yet but southerly
breezes will develop we're looking at
some south breezes right now up in the
spring mountains 40s out in prom 42 in
indian springs near 50 in mesquite 60
degrees in laughlin right now some 30s
up in caliani 34 in ely some low 40s in
tonopah here's your thursday so
we'll have some sunshine as we get
through the morning
and then even midday and then we'll see
some clouds coming back and we'll get
some southerly breezes going to push
those temperatures into our warmest day
of the week and the year so far i think
we're going to hit some low 80s today
depending on when those afternoon clouds
come back all right let's get to your
race forecast iran's i'm not sure how
much he's going to love this we got a
chance of rain coming for friday and
that's an evening race with the truck
series looks like some gusty winds still
some more rain in the forecast for
saturday and cooler temps early
afternoon races temperatures in the
upper 50s still some breezy to gusty
winds around now the pennzoil 400 looks
great
when you're out the track just make sure
you've got those big nascar jackets with
you if you're going to the racetrack
because with the winds those 50s are
going to feel extra cool for the weekend
it's all with a couple of systems moving
into the west right now pushing rain
into northern california even as far
south as the bay area this morning and
then they'll come in into the desert
dropping in but whatever moisture is
left over there is moisture but a lot of
it may be wind driven and we're not
looking for big rain totals we're not
leaving looking for a lot of snow in the
mountains but we will get it looks like
some of both so increasing winds into
tonight chance of rain into tomorrow
morning early afternoon about a 60
chance showers likely and then we take a
break friday night but again early
saturday another chance of rain with
some chillier temps in the 50s so again
it is just going to be really unsettled
for the next couple of days sunday looks
better with low 60s near 70 again next
week